[Music]
shiny test 2 is a wonderful package to
help do regression testing for your
shiny applications and we're going to
perform this regression testing
in
inside test that and it's not regression
testing like linear model or something
like that this is
a consistent behavior over time and so
we do not want it to regress or we do
not want it to change that's what i mean
for regression testing
um so shiny test two
um before we get into shiny test two and
how it works uh i just kind of wanna do
this demo app
this demo app is um
you know short little toy example we
have a fluid page that you know has a
text input it's like what's your name
you know we can fill it out
and then we also have an action button
of greet and uh
and the text greet and then we have two
text outputs uh one is a greeting like
hello barrett and then the other one is
what is the first letter in your name
and
this is neat like it's a short little
app so if i have it on here i have
barrett i click greet we get hello
barrett
and if i'm here we could do like uh
shiny text too
what is your name shiny test two greet
hello shiny test two the first letter is
s
um
so it works it's a nice little app um
the app for the server um what it does
is we have a render text that requires
the name and given a
greet click we will say hello
name
and then for the first letter
calculation we require a name and we
extract the first character of the name
and we
send it to lower and we will bind all
that calculations to when the greet
button is clicked
given this first letter whenever it
updates we will then call render text
and say the first letter in your name is
this first letter
awesome
um so let's imagine that i
have well i have now created this app or
i am working on a team and i want to
make sure that you know
behaviors are consistent and like tests
are worth so much because you don't
necessarily need to communicate that
because the test is there and if the
test breaks then we can figure out
what's happening
um and this also allows you to do other
things like sweeping code changes like
what if i want to change the guts of how
first letter is calculated i know this
is a small function but you know uh it
could be much more complicated and
having tests allow you to do these
sweeping changes with confidence
otherwise you just you just kind of look
at and go that's close enough i don't
know i hope i covered everything at
least with tests we can say all of the
tests pass and if you're missing some we
can add them in and then make your test
more robust when you run record test it
opens up your application in the chrome
browser or chromium based browser mine
by default is set to chrome
it'll have your app in this iframe
and on the sidebar is actually the
recorder
and we can see there's some buttons to
call expect shiny values or expect
screenshot
and then there's also an area of all the
code that will be executed later
to that is able to replay uh your
recording so let's make a recording this
is what is your name my name is barrett
so let's greet barrett and we'll say
hello barrett the first letter in your
name is b
and we can see that i set input's name
is barrett and then i clicked the greet
button and then an output value was
updated awesome
so i can test this or save this as hello
barrett because that is the
name that i used
and just for my reference and i'll click
oh but i need to make sure first before
because i can't save right away won't
let me so i need to say expect shiny
values
and this will keep track
uh the expect values will keep track of
all your input output and exported
values and exported values we'll get to
in another video
so once we have at least one expectation
we can then click save test and exit
this will save the test and then
immediately run the test uh play back
the test again
and uh there are some warnings because
we have some new snapshots but that's
okay
and it looks like it all passed because
there's also nothing to say that the
snapshots would fail
so let's take a look at
what was created
so we have our app.r here
awesome
and then the tests folder will be a
sibling to that
and in there we will have a test that
dot r which internally it just has shiny
test two test app
and then
next to the test.r is a test that folder
there is three parts here
the first part is the snaps folder we'll
go inside that a second in a second the
second one is the setup.r setup.r is
there for you um if when you're little
more complicated apps where you have an
r folder or you have global.r for your
shiny application we load all of those
informations inside setup.r so that your
tests have that information available
and the last one is test shiny test2
this is the default file name for
recordings and it'll say shiny test 2
recording whatever name you gave
so if we remember from
the recording that we made i created a
new app it gives the same height and
width of the recording window that way
when it replays it's under the same
height and width
we then say app set inputs i typed in
barrett for the name
i then clicked the greek button and then
we called app expect values
expect values is actually a wrapper
around shiny test or actually a wrapper
around test.expect
snapshot file
and this file will contain a json
representation of your input output and
export values
and that is stored in the snaps folder
so we will open up snaps we'll open up
shiny test2 because that is the name of
the file test shiny test2 so that name
and then there was the first json file
that was created and this one if we
click it
has my input output and export
so my inputs is at the time of calling
expect values which was after setting an
input and after clicking the greek the
greet button
we have input of greet one for one time
to click the button and name was barrett
the output was first letter was the
first letter in your name is b
and the greeting is hello barrett we
didn't export any test values yet but
we'll get into that in a later video so
this is our test this is awesome
uh we can if we want um change the
height and width we can you know add
more tests you know this is our test
file to work with
and as a side note you might notice that
there's a png file here created next to
the json file
this is there because
images
typically are fairly brittle and we
don't like to use them as if we can help
it
because there's lots of things outside
of our control that we can't you know
account for
such as you know if the r version
updates or let's say you change your
version of dt
or let's say you
update your system font or you
yeah like there's many different things
that are outside of shiny outside of r
that are not in your control
and screenshots will fail if this
happens
and that's you know no one likes to see
that but that'll happen
so if you can try to do everything as
much as possible using your json or your
values
and
try to just test the things that you own
unless you're a package developer then
you know by all means we need to start
uh taking pictures and making sure
things render properly but otherwise we
can give that responsibility back to the
package developers um not us as app
developers
but the image is there to take us a
snapshot uh to let us know what the app
looked like when we called expect values
so let's do hello barrett 001
and this will open up my application
and we can see that promote believes the
app looked like this
where it says what is your name barrett
greet hello barrett your first letter
name is b
awesome that worked out great
so one of the things that we can do
interactively is we can take our app and
we can run it in the console as long as
we're sitting in our
working directory of our shiny
application
this uses the appdriver object
and this object is something that drives
shiny test two
uh and it runs your shiny application in
the background and it also does your
communication with chrome
and so it handles all of that and
we can set our inputs we can also
retrieve out like inputs and outputs or
different values
and click you know many different things
so if we do this one of the things that
i really enjoy is that we can call app
dollar view
and view will open up a web page
of our headless
chrome browser and i think this is
really really neat because now it's not
a black box as to what is happening
[Music]
so now i have my app and this is the
uh what promote
is representing as what is the happening
within the app
so if we actually just step through this
code
uh one at a time we can actually see the
app update to the left
so we can call set input name is barrett
click greet
and then if i wanted to i could call
expect values or i could even say app
dollar
get
values
get get values and this will return all
the values
or if i wanted to do something like just
a particular one i could say app get
values with
output equals reading
and it's just that one particular value
or
since if it's just your one value um you
can say git value and it'll turn back uh
the regular result
so it's very exciting like you can debug
your headless
uh shiny application and headless chrome
instance and your shiny application all
at the same time save the codes that you
want and then we can replay them
afterwards by just going in the top
right and saying
run tests
and the ide will load up
they'll get there and eventually pass
one for that expect values because
that's the only expectation in this
whole test file test complete
perfect
[Music]
you